au collège ma prof de maths me disait
qu'il ne fallait jamais ajouter des
pommes et des bananes tandis que mon
prof d'arts plastiques disait d'ajouter
allègrement le rouge et le vert ce qui a
pas une contradiction dans cette
histoire est-ce que l'on peut vraiment
ajouter le rouge et le vert
ou est-ce juste un abus de langage et
puis c'est quoi cette histoire de
couleurs primaires
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y en a trois et
bien pour répondre à cette question
aussi fou que cela puisse paraître il va
nous falloir parler d' espaces de très
grande dimension
on y vient mais pour commencer il faut
que je vous dise que la lumière est
faite de cantat indivisible que l'on
appelle des photons chaque photon
possède une couleur cette couleur peut
être mesurée par une distance qu'on
appelait longueur d'onde ou par l'
inverse d'une durée que l'on appelle la
fréquence on va oublier un peu cet état
physique aujourd'hui ce qui compte pour
nous c'est que la lumière est faite de
photons coloré en fait les couleurs de
l'arc en ciel que l'on appelle aussi le
spectre de la lumière sont toutes les
couleurs possibles des photos mais alors
où est le marron ou et le rose où est le
blanc pour répondre à cette question il
nous faut différencier les couleurs des
photons des couleurs que nos yeux voix
et cette distinction nous amène à parler
des détecteurs de nos yeux
l'intérieur de nos yeux il est en gros
quatre types de détecteurs il y a les
bâtonnets qui capturent la lumière à
faible intensité et que l'on va oublier
pour aujourd'hui
ce qui a surtout ce sont trois
différents types de cônes 1 pour le
rouge 1 pour le verre et un pour le bleu
bon ça c'est la version simplifiée en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que chaque
caunes est capable de détecter les
photons de toutes les couleurs
différentes
mais plus ou moins facilement par
exemple comme ouvert va détecter très
facilement les photons de couleur verte
mais il va aussi capturer assez bien les
photons de couleur orange jaune
même si ans cependant les cônes rouges
eux détecte en fait très mal les faux
thon rouge
en fait sur le graphe ci dessous on se
rend compte que les cônes oranges rouges
detec en fait à peu près la même chose
que les cônes vert au mieux on peut dire
que les photons que les cônes rouge des
textes le mieux
ce sont plutôt les photons jaune mais
tout ça ce n'est pas si important
ce qui importe pour notre cerveau ce
n'est pas tant la couleur des photos qui
sont détectés mais plutôt de façon
grossière
les nombres de fautes ont détecté par
les différents détecteurs autrement dit
quand on regarde un pixel de lumière ce
qui importe c'est le nombre de photons
détectée par le code rouge ainsi que le
nombre de photons détectée par le cône
verts ainsi que le nombre de photons
détectée par le col bleu
autrement dit la couleur d'un pixel que
notre cerveau voix est en fait une
combinaison de trois nombre que les
mathématiciens appelle un vecteur de
dimension 3 et ça c'est parce que comme
la couleur d'un pixel tout point de
notre espace peut être représentée par
trois nombre que l'on appelle coordonner
un pour la direction coach droite 1 pour
la direction au bas et impôts à
direction avant arrière mais la magie
des mathématiques c'est que l'on peut
généraliser cette notion elle des
espaces de plus grande dimension
bon vous allez me dire qu'il ne s'agit
que d'une fantaisie
inutile de théoriciens allumé pourtant
pour décrire qu'entièrement un rayon de
lumière
il nous faudrait compter les nombre de
photons pour chacune des longueurs
d'onde possible or il ya un très grand
nombre voir un continuum de longueur
d'onde possible du coup nous faudrait un
nombre infini de nombre pour décrire
entièrement un rayon de lumière ainsi la
vraie couleur d'un rayon de lumière est
en fait un vecteur d'un espace de
dimension infinie et ça c'est sans doute
quelque chose que nos cerveaux ne seront
jamais capables de concevoir entièrement
et donc la couleur d'une lumière vie
dans un espace de dimension
on sent un automne nous connaît donc nos
cerveaux voit une couleur de dimension 3
alors que la vraie dimension de la
lumière on l'a dit est infini ou
quasiment infinies et ça c'est un peu
comme si on projetait l'ombre d'un objet
de dimension 3 sur un mur de dimension 2
on perd de l'information en particulier
il va y avoir des objets différents de
dimension 3 qui vont avoir la même
nombre je vous invite d'ailleurs à les
voir la vidéo de micmacs à ce sujet qui
montre aussi des projections dans
l'espace de dimension 3 d'objets de
dimensions 4 bref tout ça pour dire que
des couleurs de lumières différentes
vont être indiscernable pour nos yeux
par exemple si je prends un citron la
couleur des photons que je vois va être
différente de celle que vous vous voyez
pour moi la couleur de ce site on est
faite essentiellement de photons jaune
mais vous derrière votre écran vous ne
voyez aucun faux thon jaune et ça c'est
parce que votre écran est incapable
d'afficher des photons de couleur jaune
en fait votre écran n'est capable
d'afficher que du rouge du vert et du
bleu
mais voilà ce qui se passe quand on
expose nos yeux à des photons jaune
uniquement noooon rouge et vert vont
s'activer et détecter des photons mais
pas nos cous bleus
de la même façon si on est exposé à des
faux thon rouge et vert les mêmes codes
vont s'activer et détecter les mêmes
nombre de photons et donc l'information
envoyée à notre cerveau qui est le
vecteur des nombres de fautes ont
détecté par les différents détecteurs va
être le même dans les deux cas
nos cerveaux ne peuvent pas discerner
des photons jaune d'une combinaison de
faux thon rouge et vert en fait parce
que nous ne voyons qu'une couleur de
dimension 3 il suffit de combiner trois
couleurs de photons pour produire toutes
les couleurs accessible à l'oeil ou non
ces trois couleurs sont le rouge le vert
et le bleu c'est en cela que ce sont des
couleurs primaires
il se passe donc c'est que le vecteur de
dimension infinie qu'est la couleur de
la lumière a été réduit en un vecteur de
dimension 3 on parle de projection
s'agit même d'une projection linéaire
parce que les opérations qui permettent
de passer du premier vecteur au second
consiste uniquement à additionner les
nombre de photons de la bonne manière
en particulier je peux enfin vous dire
ce que signifie ajouté deux couleurs ça
veut dire que je ne vais ajouter que les
photons de la même couleur
dans cet exemple simpliste où il n'y a
que trois couleurs de photons plutôt
qu'une infinité
ceci correspond à ajouter d'un côté des
photons verre ensemble puis les photons
orange ensemble et enfin les photons ci
ont ensemble
l'opération que l'on vient de faire
correspond globalement à l'addition 4 2
1 + 1 6 1 qui nous a donné 5 8 2 ce que
l'on vient de faire racing c'est une
addition de vecteurs ce n'est pas juste
une simple addition de deux nombres
c'est plutôt une sorte de super
additions et cette super addition qui
est aujourd'hui le coeur d'études de
soupe qu'on appelle l'algèbre linéaire
est vraiment au coeur de plein de
domaines des sciences des mathématiques
et la physique en passant par la
biologie et l'économie bref je vous
rassure ce genre de super addition est
vraiment super utile peut dire qu'il est
au coeur du big data
ce qui est fou c'est que quand on dit
que rouge plus vrai régal jaune c'est
quasiment une super addition de vecteurs
et ça il faut que je précise que ce dont
je parle ici et bien l'addition des
lumières au napa 6 qui ont fait plus tôt
c'est de l'addition des peintures et en
fait l'addition des peintures c'est
vraiment pas une édition c'est plutôt
une espèce de soustraction n'essaie pas
non plus une soustraction en fait c'est
un vrai abus de langage mathématique en
tout cas que d'appeler ça une
soustraction pour en savoir plus sur ce
sujet je vous invite à les voir viviane
sur syllabus enfin dans cette histoire
on peut vouloir se demander si les
chiens voit les mêmes couleurs que non
et là la réponse est clairement non
les chiens en haut plutôt deux cônes de
couleur et du coup voir une couleur qui
n'est que deux dimensions 2 et qu'il est
donc moins riche que la nôtre mais à l
inverse il ya des oiseaux qui ont quatre
cônes de couleurs et donc la couleur
qu'il voit c'est un objet de dimensions
4 comco la dimension 4 ça existe et pas
que dans les vidéos de micmacs plus fou
encore la crevette menthe usto
motopompes aux ducks tomates ou sinon de
biologistes lac revêtement l ascèse
caunes différent et ça ça veut dire que
la couleur qu'elle voit et de dimensions
16 c'est un truc de fou
sérieusement à y voir de sting sur smart
grid à la crevette menthe
je suis fan allez j'espère que vous avez
aimé cet épisode j'espère qu'il vous
fera voir littéralement le monde sous
une autre couleur pour en savoir plus
sur les couleurs ou pour mieux
comprendre toute l'histoire que nous la
raconter je vous invite fortement à les
regarder la vidéo de david diop sur son
étonnante et je trouve ça aussi
intéressant que david lui cet interdit
de parler de couleurs de photons il ne
parle que de longueur d'onde et je pense
que niveau pédagogique c'est une
question intéressant de savoir ce qu'il
vaut mieux faire comme la faiblesse que
ce n'est pas trop dérangeant de parler
de couleurs de photons mois il sauf que
dans mon cas c'était utile de donner des
couleurs aux photons pour pouvoir
illustrer l'addition vectorielle au
final je pense que le mieux c'est encore
d'avoir les deux versions et de regarder
les deux versions et de faire le lien
entre ma vidéo et surtout celle de david
j'espère aussi qu'ils vous aura aidé à
avoir une intuition de ce que pourrait
être un espace temps de dimensions 4 du
cac un espace de dimensions 4 ceci dit
on relativité générale l'espace temps
lui est courbé et ceux dont on a parlé
aujourd'hui est un espace plein même si
ce n'est pas forcément clair au vu de
cette vidéo c'est pourquoi au cours des
prochains épisodes on va parler d'eux
géométrie un peu plus court un peu plus
nos kids yen dont on les appelle en
particulier pour la prochaine fois la
question à laquelle j'aimerais que vous
réfléchissiez sait si on prend une
feuille de papier carré est ce qu'il est
possible de joindre les bords opposés du
carré et si possible sans faire de pub
et que comme chanteur est ce qu'il est
possible de coller les côtés opposés
d'un carré
c'est la question à laquelle j'aimerais
que vous réfléchissiez vous pouvez
mettre votre idée de réponse dans les
commentaires si vous voulez si vous avez
des questions à l'issue de cet épisode
mettez les dans les commentaires ça me
fera très plaisir à voir des messages de
votre part même si ce n'est pas une
question d'ailleurs si vous avez aimé
cet épisode laïque et le partagez le
et j'espère que je vous verrai la
prochaine fois si je joue deux notes en
même temps vous pouvez les distinguer
toutes les deux alors que si je vous
balance deux ondes électromagnétiques en
même temps vous voyez une espèce de
moyenne des deux si les jambes ça veut
dire qu'il a absorbé toutes les couleurs
sauf le jeune donc oui il devrait avoir
peu chaud